president biden getting testy with the
media and lying his butt off about
inflation the commander-in-chief claims
he deserves no blame whatsoever for the
economy while denying his reckless
spending led to record prices quote
the idea that it caused inflation is
bizarre if it's my fault why is it the
other major industrial why is it the
case that in every other major
industrial country in the world that
inflation is higher you asked yourself
that i'm not being a wise guy that's the
end of the quote peter ducey pressing
the white house on that whopper of a
claim
he says that inflation is worse
everywhere but here that's not true u.s
has worse inflation in germany france
japan canada india italy saudi arabia
what why is he saying i think what we
are saying is that uh
when you talk about inflation it is a
global thing and it is not just about
the united states this is something that
everyone is feeling because of coming
out of once once in a lifetime pandemic
because of the war that russia has
started in ukraine
and after blabbing away to the ap it
seems like those close to the president
didn't want him to do any more talking
[Music]
the white house is also now considering
trying to buy voters off by sending
americans gas rebate cards to offset the
surge in prices
there's so many places i can start but
i'm not starting with you greg because
you put your hand in front of the
teleprompter so joey i'm going to start
with you so the president says
specifically if it's my fault why is it
the case in every other major industrial
country in the world that inflation is
higher now uh
they can make every excuse they want but
he lied
he lied or he's incompetent which is it
the most surprising thing is that she
didn't make a good excuse you have so
many ways to spin it that she could have
found some little small group of
countries that have something in common
and say but we're better than they are
and that's why i have that list i
haven't um and so you know so maybe
jessica there's another job out there
for you maybe are you trying to get rid
of me no i'm just saying a lot of people
could do better from that podium i think
i think uh jinsaki did a tremendous job
now that i have something to compare to
uh but listen i saw a video on instagram
of all places dave congressman jason
smith um
nice enough guy don't know much about
him but he's grilling janet yellen and
he gets her to admit that their strategy
for reducing inflation in part is to
reduce deficit because that's one of the
things they think they've gotten right
and when you look at how they reduce
deficit it's laughable but if reducing
deficit reduces inflation then it
doesn't take a very smart person to say
that increasing government spending
maybe increases inflation and i really
wish you would have driven that point
home because i think that's the point
that if you got janet yellen to admit
then joe biden does have to accept
responsibility for the majority of this
problem you know any leader
worth his or her salt
would admit
would empathize and would offer a
solution this president is incapable as
much as people thought he empathized
about covet he is incapable of accepting
the fact that he is responsible for what
has happened in to this economy and he's
doing nothing as he continues to trash
fossil fuels well he isn't wrong and
karine jean-pierre isn't wrong as well
that this is a global problem but he is
the president of one country no
but no don't you can't just leave it at
that he said every other major country
obviously you misspoke on that i have
the numbers
there are 20 countries doing
better than we are donald trump
in the whole world is what we're talking
about
last week you get no but how many
countries are we considering here
because last week you threw out a list
and you included the philippines on it
philippines is not related at all to
what's going on here in the u.s
countries that are related germany the
uk netherlands spain yes brazil higher
spain 9.8 percent netherlands nine point
seven
eight point four what
you can't that's a lie this admitted
it's
if you think the lie to me has malicious
intent the president should not have
said that he should say we are facing a
global challenge
we are running basically in the middle
of the pack here accept the economic
situation that they're in and say you
have no responsibility for it that's
about as malicious i don't think you
should say you have no responsibility
that seems to be what he's trying to do
it's just strange to me i guess that you
could watch joe biden say this and be
screaming about you're a liar or you're
incompetent obviously he just he doesn't
want to acknowledge that things that he
did ended up pushing us in this
direction and people from his former
team certainly people from the body
administration have written op-eds about
it and said that we spent too much janet
yellen has admitted that she wanted the
american rescue act to be about half the
size that it ended up being that is a
fine argument to make to adults in this
country who understand generally
speaking that we are part of a
globalized economy that we needed a
bailout to some degree but perhaps it
went too far and i think that changing
course on that and showing that coveted
empathy from the campaign trail would
benefit him but
his back is up against the wall and he
doesn't want to do it so i
okay all right so he's so tone deaf
and so clueless that he's now hosting a
meeting greg
on climate change when people can't
afford gas to drive to work well i think
that's you know that's the bigger story
you know i i'm kind of with jessica on
this the
accusing politicians of lying is like
accusing birds of
chirping it's just in their dna i will i
have to point out that we are part of a
globalized economy but we have to
remember that as america goes so goes
the world i think
biden likes to pretend that it's the
reverse but no it's like when we do well
they do well when we do poorly they do
poorly so it's like the inflation our
high inflation
is kind of responsible for a lot of
other high inflations and i'm saying
that as a phd
economic economic economicist i'm an
economicist all right so the blame game
the this is where the blame game i think
matters to you to your question the way
how the white house has the hierarchy of
needs backwards all we want right now
when we talk about this
food on the table fuel in your car
law and order on the streets in your
hierarchy of needs that's what people
want not solar panels
not cricket recipes not drag shows for
kids those are all the fun things you
can have when everything else is great
okay you know what i mean in the
hierarchy of needs you have to have the
food the fuel the law order then let's
talk about sending drag drag performers
to grade schools but don't do that right
now when people are suffering worse we
have replaced self-reliance with
self-actualization
so a lot of these young people in the
white house they don't know how to solve
actual problems however if you need an
instagram photo during a special month
or a special day and and you say you
know what to say that they can do they
can ace that but if you talk about gas
prices or if you talk about baby formula
if you talk about war if you talk all
these bigger issues they do not know
what to do and the real example here is
you know they just appointed kamala
harris to run another like on
anti-online harassment board and it's
like that does nothing to help anybody
that is like again this kind of virtue
signaling external behavior that is just
purely symbolic and no practical value
whatsoever judge i love your jacket it's
very colorful
i can tell you're not impressed with me
but that's okay it's friday okay deagon
listen you're you're really you're the
numbers person you're the economist here
i don't buy it you know what
to me someone who is the president of
the greatest country on earth has an
obligation to be truthful to the people
who voted for him the 80 million who
voted for him all right so when he comes
out and says don't blame me
you know uh blame putin i don't see
anybody running around saying you know
that damn putin he's responsible for
this and he says inflation is worse
everywhere but here and then he talks
about the fact that you know
he says that
the american that he inherited a bad
economy
did he inherit a bad economy he
inherited an economy that was recovering
from covet and he under he brags about
job creation we're still
short i think it's roughly about 800 000
jobs from we're not even back to the
employment we had before the coveted
lockdowns
but if what job if joe biden's strategy
is going to be to jackie jaw and flap
his gums and talk and [ __ ] and moan and
get mad then he should come out and say
i will veto anything that will increase
government spending for the foreseeable
future until we get
uh inflation under control and that
means the pa the student uh the
moratorium on student loan payments
that's money that's going to rich kids
who are doctors and lawyers
that runs until at least august you
watch them they will probably wind up
extending it so he could at least do
that but they're taking it one step
further this is the the level of idiocy
that we're talking about from this white
house they're talking about gas rebates
this is what anybody in that white house
knows this from the econ 101 that they
took in undergraduate school the dumbest
thing that you can do when you're trying
to fight inflation do not give money out
to buy a commodity that is in limited
supply that you already have access
demand they're literally handing money
to people to juice demand when supplies
are tight yeah that is
beyond more honesty
and they will continue to do this the
this we're probably already in a
recession it's going to take a deep
recession to fix this inflation and joe
biden will own it all day long every day
because he reappointed jay powell as the
head of the federal reserve when he
could have fired him and they and they
didn't i'm not gonna lie i don't
understand the economy any better but
you guys just expanded my vocabulary by
about 12 words so what here's another
one in i'm calling it the in biden
session because stagflation's not going
to be enough it's inflation with biden
in the middle and a recession on the end
okay hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else